[Music]
hey everyone it is jessie from the tasty
team and today I'm testing up five
famous celebrity chicken wing recipes to
see which one is actually the best on
taste line up I have recipes from Gordon
Ramsay John Legend Emeril Lagasse Martha
Stewart and football champion Joe
Montana
I might found all the ingredients
exactly as the recipes are stated and I
got three friends to taste him in a
blind cases so was this chicken wing
recipe
let's find out first up is Gordon Ramsay
he does this fancy technique called a
lollipop egg which she takes drumettes
and he kind of pushes the meat up
towards the top so you get this nice
clean bone that you can pick up when
you're eating and your fingers don't get
all messy so do that toll them send my
side and in a pan combine honey olive
oil free space which is a type of hot
chilli paste in both lima zest and juice
and cook that up and took it's nice and
thick then with those lollipop drumettes
season them up with olive oil salt and
pepper toss them together and scatter
them on a parchment lined sheet tray pop
those in the oven and while those are
cooking you're gonna make your own
dipping sauce combined yogurt cilantro
lime zest garlic lime juice and a bit of
salt and mix that all together set that
aside and bring back your cooked wings
take the prepared sauce and brush them
all over the wings flipping them once so
you can brush them on all sides pop them
back into the oven and this is just so
they get nice and sticky and the sauce
has time to thicken up plate those up
and garnish with toasted sesame seeds
and sliced scallions and serve them with
prepared dipping sauce and there you
have it
Gordon Ramsay's fancy chicken wings oh
right
I like the sesame seed detail that's
kind of cool into that your skin is not
stripper oily they didn't need to be
sesame on that that's just pretentious
or something
it's sweet and then this is like a
little bit savory
I really like the dip it's like wait
and zesty like there's really no taste
of the chicken but the sour cream and
onion dips grape it's really delicious
the wing is juicy which is nice the
sesame seeds definitely like that and
it's a really pretty presentation
normally I have never eaten a wing with
less seats on it before but it's good I
like it
up next is John Legend he starts the day
before by making a brine with water
seasoned salt cayenne pepper garlic
powder and mix that all together and
adding wings to it he lets this brine
for 4 to 24 hours before he gets started
on the wings while that's happening a
large bowl combine melted butter hot
sauce and honey mix that all up until
thick sauce forms this is what you'll
toss the wings in later the next side
combine flour kind pepper and seasoned
salt this is what we're gonna toss the
wings in bring back your brined wings
toss them in the flour and put them on a
sheet tray
have a Dutch oven filled with canola oil
and heat it up until 360 degrees you're
gonna fry the wings in small batches for
about 13 minutes until they're golden
and cooked through draining them on a
paper towel lined plate each time a
large bowl toss the wings with the
prepared hot sauce until they're nice
and coated and there you have it John
Legend's crispy fried chicken wings with
spicy honey butter whoa RA it looks
crisp no sauce I never picked this one
when I get wings I only want drumsticks
if I made chicken wings I would want it
to look like this
hmm little good I like this one there's
a kick to it but it's also sweet it's so
good my god this one is a little bit on
the sweeter side too you can feel like a
little tiny kick but is nothing too
crazy I still think I need a sauce but
overall I really do like this way I
jelly honey on it I think I'm like a
regular circular hot dog it's really
like tender which I like the crust is a
little crunchy it's like sweet with a
kick I really like it up next is Emeril
Lagasse he starts by making his own blue
cheese dipping sauce by combining blue
cheese sour cream mayonnaise butter milk
fresh lemon juice minced garlic salt and
pepper and mixing that all up we're
going to set that aside and we're gonna
serve that with the wings later next
Emma makes his own hot sauce by
combining hot sauce with apple cider
vinegar and sugar keep it up and we're
slowly going to add some softened butter
using a hand mixer just to make sure it
almost lies we do this in a few steps
just to make sure we're not overloading
with butter step this aside when it
comes time to make the actual wings
combine flour salt pepper and cayenne
and mix it all together bring in some
wings and we're gonna put these in
ziplock baggies with the flour and shake
it all up just to make sure they're nice
and evenly coated his recipe says to
shake it all up in a bag but we had to
use two just because there's enough
wings to fit in to dump these out onto a
sheet tray and let it dry for about an
hour
once those are dried fry those in a
large cast iron pot filled with oil at
350 degrees in batches until they're
nice and golden this takes about 10 to
13 minutes per batch take those wings
and toss them in the hot sauce you
prepared earlier just so they're nice
and evenly coated
serve these with celery carrots and the
prepared blue cheese dipping sauce and
emeralds wings are done whoo all right
this looks like a Pizza Hut wing and
it's good and that's a good thing
see this is the kind of wing that I'm
used to getting at the restaurants I
always like when the wings come with the
the carrots and celery even though I
don't eat it at all I hope you cheat my
favorite
pretty standard pretty regular it's good
I'm not super crazy about it but it's
good yeah Pizza Hut wing or just like a
regular bar like on the average level
there's like nothing special about it
but there's nothing wrong with it it's
like such a classic um delicious feeling
that you'd know just by looking at it
like just by the color of the way like
what - tastes like exactly and that is
what it tastes like it's a as a buffalo
wing I'm always a person ate it it's a
palate cleanser next up is Martha
Stewart she starts by tossing wings with
salt a large bowl and scatter them onto
a baking tray with no oil or parchment
paper and baking them until crispy in a
separate bowl combine maple syrup grainy
Dijon mustard and stir that all together
once baked take those wings and toss
them directly in the sauce give him a
nice coat you're gonna pop these back
into the oven just so the glaze has time
to kind of stick to it and thicken up a
bit about two to three minutes serve
them with lemon wedges and that's it
Martha Stewart's super simple wing
recipe
this has a cute little glaze to it it's
got little seeds on it and the lemon
served with a lemon so we're trying to
be fancy
is it mustard seeds this comes with a
slice of lemon and since it's here I'm
just gonna squeeze it on there's like
kind of no taste but then there's also
kind of a taste it's not quite sweet
it's pretty neutral but it's good like I
want to take another bite it's sweet
it's just sweet I know I don't like that
there was a lemon lift here cuz it's
like why would I do that I feel like
this is probably like a healthier
version of a chicken wing I really have
no idea what's in this wing I think
that's what got me is coz the outside is
like a yummy glazed layer and then the
inside is like pretty tender
I'm not mad but I wouldn't order this
percent last but not least is football
legend Joe Montana in a bowl he combines
salt pepper seasoned salt onion powder
garlic powder and paprika and stirs that
all up to create his own seasoning blend
set that aside and take a large bowl and
add whole beings to it with the tips cut
off toss those in a bit of oil then take
half the seasoning mixture and toss it
right on top finish it with the
remaining so it's nice and evenly coated
and transfer these wings onto a baking
tray with a baker's rack scatter those
around and pop in the oven and that's
really it that's joe Montana's full
chicken wing recipe it's just cute it's
pretty standard it's got a little oil
you know it's like the kind where you
like you know you're gonna need a little
nap can and maybe a little like a wet
wipe this doesn't look like wings
necessarily I can see this in the cup
wael tray I look up barbecue it's very
juicy I like it it honestly days ago
rotisserie chicken have some good spices
could have a little bit more this is
good but it doesn't have a super ton of
flavor I think a dipping sauce would be
nice this side tastes like if you're
just like getting a piece of rotisserie
chicken with your meal which I love I
love her to surgery I love sodium maybe
this would be in like your meal prep
rotation which is fine it's good very
moist and delicious but like not as a
hot wing out of the five I think four
and five are out for me I like one two
and three I like the sauces because I'm
not the hugest fan of buffalo wings I'm
cutting three but because the first moon
had the sauce and I'm someone who's
lactose intolerant and can't help myself
I'm gonna go with one because I love
dipping the way in sighs okay hey Gordon
chef and all no it's good I guess sauce
is delicious so I think my favorite wing
was the first one I got they had the
sesame seeds it had a really dope sauce
easy to bite into was tender had a nice
little layer sweet so other things I'm
looking for in a way Gordon Ramsay oh
okay so eating some fancy wings up in
here out of the five winds I ate I think
number two is the best wasn't like a
crazy taste there was a little bit of a
kick to it it was a little bit sweet and
it was fried which I like I like fried
and baked but that tasted really good
and his moist oh and he's great he does
no wrong he's got an e got he has all
the words the chicken wings on Chris
he's thinking foot that's great yeah
they're really do that's good I like
them even more that I know he got that
so there you have it
Gordon Ramsay has the best chicken wing
recipe which recipe do you want us to
test next let us know in the comments oh
yes
[Music]
you
[Music]